bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vigente sono qua con
giorgio che vedendo il letto dietro
abbiamo appena finito di fare il sesso e
siamo qua non ridere che ha goduto pure
questa cosa ragazze
vai a giocare forte vai vai a giocare
dice siamo ragazzi nel sahara diere dur
ve lo dico anche qui almeno locate ma
[ __ ] siamo sul server di e ridurre
e mi sto facendo crescere i baffi presso
migliaia lui ha carta ragazzi siamo in
gruppo tra l'altro se questi cavalli
stanno facendo cose che non vorreste
sapere siamo in gruppo io e giorgio e
dobbiamo solo che minchia che sentito
maurizio merli tentation cava niente te
uscito siamo su drakensang che è immensi
come la trota ho fatto league of angels
mi avete chiesto di rifare le roba
online perché c'è questo vol cavallo che
si crede figo 20th baciato li faccio
vedere chi ha il cazzo più lungo mettiti
giunti guarda quello che harry potter
ave ragazzi allora giorgio e il web a un
guerriero warrior io invece ho un mago e
dove le mazzate perché la mazza ma tanto
questo da
e questa una questa al 36 a secco ognuno
però sta dicendo a me a secco per sé
successo all'acquedotto non lo so
andiamo a vedere cassetta sorpresa
piccola ricevuto in dono un ramo grazie
grazie
dato che che nomi belli abbiamo scelto
re giorgio shadow lo giuro che fai
veramente cagare addosso l'un questo
nome incute paura volete fare già tre
falli gevi the greeks l'handbike wav e
guardo toccarle il dottor carella zin
del tocco lezione vai anche tu eccoci ci
siamo restiamo tutti io la dai e faccio
io di ps forte scandita tutan caput anca
ti faccio una domanda è stata se tu devi
tank aree che cosa ci faccio io davanti
ma fai qualcosa perché io mi chiamo
l'aria di chiavi ilaria ma guarda che è
ilaria ma smettila
vai a mani nude vitalcare il giorgio ma
ti lascio italiane quando ti lascio da
solo giorno picchiatore mica mi sembra
uscito dai futura ma questo e quello e
joey burns sono morto
la casta non sai neanche far quello che
sta maturando giorno hai fatto anche a
quanta vita e tu sei pieno comunque noi
ragazzi facciamo c'è un appunto è perché
sono gli account ce li hanno fatti
perché se non sai dovevamo farci il
tutorial e non troviamo provato a fare
il tutorial ci siamo riusciti dopo due
ore dal tutorial quindi non sappiamo
giocare non prendeteci come esempio
perché facciamo veramente pagare abruzzo
parlando all'inizio lo facciamo pagare a
come potevi usare le altre scritte cosa
cazzo sei bellissima
hai visto del sentiero sei venuto alla
visto come faccio a col tasto destro
minchia non sai neanche tank aree vuoi
farmi capire dove dobbiamo andare
facevamo le porte pci avanti e che botta
fortissima
c'è un tomo leggilo libro di elettronica
quelle che sono un mago più forte della
terra avada kedavra e non è neanche
morti erano gioia nella mia vita non
posso usare l'esperto patron però il
bilancio questa palla forte che se non
ti uccide fortifica ci siano ferro tra
presa di tutti fa qualcosa cerchiari
tanca relativa dorsali stom almeno di
fare una cosa giorgio la mazza celano è
la mazza lo sapevo ieri notte ne sono
accorti io apro forte lo scrigno cosa
accede scrigno leggendario servono 100
grimaldello acquista cento ma io big
money 4.000 alter gm li compro apre lo
scrigno ho ricevuto gesù cappuccio
nostro tratto due leggendarie zio butta
il grembiule tutto ci hanno trovato in
tutte le leggendarie ma tu non ce l'hai
se non sei povero da svegli e senza la
distruzione mi serve perché sono mago
non è vero serviva tetro [ __ ] anche
la cintura città non c'avevo proprio ceo
di calvin klein
adesso sono molto più shiva musica un
cambio al bastone zio con questo quadro
il filo che è un piacere a perché il
bastone a due mani li mortacci mia non
aspetta forse la più forte prima a
[ __ ] sulla un aiuto avviso ma se sei
un tanto al 40 non mi aiuta mbia
l'equipaggiamento arrivo a questi sono
gli amici che ti lasciano morire se per
un'ora e mezza si sa i fatti i cazzi
tuoi deficiente arrivo arrivo arrivo
arriva arriva rivali fortissimo ha la
chiara avrà sto morendo seria mica se
non c'ero io
se non c'ero io neanche a casa arriva
dopo crittato zio lorca pacca quanto sto
togliendo a perché leggo 300 per cento
in più con la sfera che l'avevano sotto
tutti che va perché me la sfera che leva
altre cerchietti aumenta il 300 per
cento di danno scenica è troppo e opi e
troppo cuore ma il mago zio che cazzo ne
scuso io ho sempre visto il reporter per
un motivo
ho imparato le arti in gara insidiosa
devi stare lontano quando le meduse
esplodono zio ma davvero è già magari
un'arte venire in mente di di tuo ha
detto che esplode è bravi hai capito
tutto quello che ti ho detto infatti io
c'ho al teletrasporto gara di coppa
quanto mi faccio il viaggio così io così
conquisto la [ __ ] c'è un tipo ciao io i
999 vieni che aspetta che io sono nato
io sono più forte vieni qua per
spettavano faccia amico io io so come
farmi gli amici io ricco love io ricco
invita gli olivi riquadri con soldi sia
sto più estesi a noi amici cosa non
capisci la parola fermo zio fai parlare
ma che io sono bravo con le persone che
i can't make più stronger aimeri give
you are my mia cagato di street dove è
arrivato un altro però ha sentito
richiamo di risorse che se uno legge
giorgio shadow fine ironia stargard
questa qua e tele porta new non possiamo
andarci con questa gara ci sono remore
va bene torria scure di vedetta vero ce
la stiamo cavando è si parla per te
cento ed inserendo pian piano piano fa
ragazzi piano la madre eva joe aiuto
quanta roba oggi non mi morire non mi
morire gioco sono martina come mi piace
la caveranno guardato la vita 262
istantanea misto rivitalizzando perché
io punti quindi possono bello e lo
faccio picchia più forte
poi è facile facce da c gioioso abbiano
ucciso di nuovo faccio pagare
committente no e non è un boss non amico
però c'è il prigioniero ciao
adesso noi dobbiamo seviziare di più sì
mi piace guardare queste cose si
continua giorgio che dai a parte sa che
ha cantato ma se non si ancora molto
anche una volta mi date ammazzo io a
dire un boss si scende si guarda sommo
giusto che cosa il sogno si metta spetta
ai vediamolo insomma siamo contro i boss
dove arias nominando te anche un
efficiente credo che il vostro sito
christophe veri che se non molliamo
dobbiamo imprecare molte volte che
propone che mortale via montale che
morto su cristo il pugno sul g8 della
potenza pur kabu porca eva lercia
cos'è sta roba giorgio 0 piano non
moriamo che dio c'è ancora vivo se sì ma
come arriva arrivati con forte arrivo
forte ma tutto 26 nasco guarda che fallì
informers cafoni abbandonata io sono un
mago a meno picchio l'aria però se
picchia l'aria sono porta veri porta di
quella era così di costo di un'ora e
mezza io sono di piccola suo cognome io
quanta verità c'è questo non muore mai
oppure vai ceco cielo scuro strano
vieni a pestare questo morte morte morte
durato più lui del vostro ragazzo esco
io fresati dai dai dai massacrando noi
cazzo sei dal destino joma donna doveva
che si sa se vai verso il traguardo si
sono degli gnomi con l'ascia corri corri
c'è un gigante della mole ma cos'è
questa roba sacerdote superiore drago
idea guarda quanto oro premio per
batterlo tutto questo oro che c'è
intorno all'uno e sono molto sono molto
sono molto sudore l'ho preso l'ho preso
l'ho preso
ci penso io ci penso io stanco io che
sono un mago
strano ma fai qualcosa sto morendo ad
ora stai massei war normali procedure di
vita guarda guarda aspettarmi nascosa
morendo attaccano adesso giorno
cercando io voglio fare momento io ho
fatto stava morendo 8 io ma edizione si
valida mistico a svegliare vuol dire che
adesso possiamo avere tutto questo ora
come mimì destreggiò sull'oro ti piace
tipo paperon de paperoni delle portare
un ok dentro minchia non ci possono
stare
da giorno ragazzuoli questa è stata la
ma vieni qua abbiamo massacrato
qualsiasi cosa d'estate mi sfidi che
cazzo hai fatto per cento delle uscite
io sono riuscito a non morire via sono
morto 800 è il tuo compito è quello di
non farmi morire non hai fatto un cazzo
va bè ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
santo cosa questo è un potere che che
sovrasta quello dei maghi entrai a spero
che vi sia piaciuto come sempre stato
commento è un mi piace anche la pace di
facebook e co minivideo data
nell'edizione di server dove abbiamo
giocato lo abbiamo fatto vedere
all'inizio quindi nel caso andata
all'inizio del video che c'è il server
quello forte
se non siete iscritti ancora iscrivetevi
e ma io sto cercando un telecomando
capiamo non hai fatto un cazzo tutto il
gioco premi almeno di telecomando grazie
e ligia una cosa devi fare una cosa a
rischio grazie è gentilissimo senza
vestiti stia televisivi diavolo
proseguito bella ragazzi il collo
depilati quando il tempo comunque
crederci
bella tutti ragazzi è benvenuto